valve finally fixed CS2 well for the
most part people have had a few days to
test it out and so far it feels
playable the abysmal net code and the
Havoc it wrought on hit reg spray
control and peaker's Advantage has been
improved dramatically but in doing so
valve hard locked all servers to 64k for
how long we don't know to what end
we don't know will subtik ever actually
feel as good as 128.
we don't know
all right so before we start smack
talking tick rates a friendly reminder
to check out our fantastic series into
the dark we partnered up with our
friends over at Kraken to produce some
Next Level storytelling about esports's
most revered Risk Takers Counter-Strike
fans will surely Rejoice at our simple
and twists episodes which I got to be a
part of so check them out okay
CS2 so late last week valve released two
updates that significantly improved
cs2's player experience the changes were
miraculous life-changing and quite
frankly needed I'm sure I don't need to
tell any of you that prior to these
updates virtually every aspect of the
gun play felt horrendous like truly dog
even when you did pop off it didn't
feel good
there it is baby the worst part is that
from what I and many others understand
it wasn't because of the engine it was
because of the netcode the community was
very quick to blame the so-called
sub-tick infrastructure that valve
started hyping up way back in March
since it felt significantly worse than
csgo's existing third-party 128 tick
infrastructures now the tip rate no
longer matters for moving and shooting
so the server will know the exact moment
to fired your shot jumped your jump or
peaked your Peak and the server will
calculate your precise actions between
ticks
so what you see is what you get so that
was a [__] lie memes aside I do think
it's worth taking a second to stop and
just earnestly ask what exactly is
subject because in the last couple of
weeks have taught me anything it's that
the answer to that question isn't
actually all that clear according to
valve it's this less than a tick system
that improves upon csgo's previous 64
tick servers except it didn't
at all don't get me wrong CS goes to 64
tick servers we're always floaty and
felt sort of bad and were rightly
maligned but up until a couple of days
ago cs2's servers felt infinitely worse
Not only was the game outright
unplayable on high ping but spraying hit
Rag and peaker's Advantage were in the
sh and let's just say it got on a fair
number of people's nerves
foreign
what is this spray myself included
please just die please just die I hate
the spraying I hate the spraying so much
please just die oh my God the AKA just
feels so bad now again everyone and
their mother started blaming this
so-called subject stuff that has sponge
rightly observed on hltv confirmed no
one can actually seem to wrap their head
around subtik is just what CS2 exists
upon when we play on the server but
there's still these variables that rep
that are representative of a 64 tick or
128 tick experience now this is where I
wish I knew more about what everything
that went in goes into service now this
feels like nobody really actually knows
that's the problem like even from all
the leakers and people who like claim to
have some sort of knowledge they
disagree about what it actually means
the amount of checks it's the amount of
checks that are happening in a in a
period of time right so like a tick like
when something happens on an exact time
YouTube videos of people going look at
this idiot talking about exactly the
problem no idea about yeah it really
does feel as if subtik has sort of
become this like abstract philosophical
pseudo-religious concept that people
tell you they understand until they have
to explain it to you and then it sort of
becomes this circular recursive thing of
just well it's sub tick you see so it's
less than a tick and then you ask what
that is and they just go back to saying
well it's below tick right and then you
just find yourself in this place of like
wait why is it that we couldn't just
have 128 tick across the board like why
is it we had to split the [__] tick
at the atomic level so that I could
click a mouse and just have it work
anyway look I sure should have no idea
what any of this subject stuff means but
then again I am not particularly
technologically savvy when it comes to
any sort of networking stuff other more
intelligent people like data Miner game
follower explained how both mm and face
it were making use of subtik but only
for certain in-game events and the issue
was that it wasn't evident which events
were using which infrastructure what
this meant apparently is that there
should have been little to no difference
between faceit and MF even though
everyone who'd played CS2 on face had
said It felt noticeably better another
word you've probably heard being thrown
around these past couple of weeks is
interpolation now I had no concept of
what that meant until I stumbled upon a
helpful Tick Tock by a Creator named
wilbox who took pains to explain what it
is and how CS2 allegedly [__] it up so
bad interpolation is a technique that
makes movement of players look very
smoother interpolation does have a Costo
it adds a bit of delay and csgo at delay
was about 30 milliseconds that means
basically the Ping of everyone increased
by 30 which is preferable to playing
against this choppy mess in CS2 though
wealth bumped up the interpolation way
too high increasing the delay from 30
milliseconds to 200 that is six times
slower and of course people said you'd
be able to rectify set issues by
inserting a handful of commands into
your console which as it turns out was
complete and utter baloney the reality
is that none of us seem to have a very
clear idea as to why CS2 felt like only
that it felt like and I want to be clear
it felt like
the peaker's advantage was undeniably
awful and gave way to this sort of Swing
or be swung upon meta where you had to
execute fools or just be executed opting
was laughably bad and you just couldn't
take a fair or even advantageous
gunfight with a rifle and be confident
that you would win you just couldn't the
reason I felt this so acutely is because
I haven't fully switched I still play CS
go a couple nights a week for esea
league so I would do this thing where
I'd play CS go for a couple hours and
then switch to CS2 to pog with my
friends and notice how jarring the
difference actually was and then on
Wednesday valve did that super Val thing
where they just released an update and
innocuous looking update with a single
offhand line smack dab in the middle
that just magically made everything
better and by better I mean better not
perfect not even close just
better the next day they released yet
another update with yet another single
all-powerful line of text that improved
the player experience even further and I
gotta say the second I loaded it up I
immediately noticed the difference
oh yes nice shot now to be fair I don't
think it feels even close to us
excellent as 128 tick CS go it's just
not there yet
the question is whether it will ever be
you see one of the things we learned
since these updates is that valve have
now hard-coded 64 tick tick rates to CS2
like to the client according to data
Miner and steam DB founder Pavel jundic
even other third-party servers like
faceits cannot run at 128 tick until
valve reverts this setting so there's
two big concerns surrounding this one
what does this spell for face it the
short answer is
it's valve
who knows turns out that's the answer to
a lot of questions surrounding
Counter-Strike valve may end up
loosening this lock since they are
currently troubleshooting a beta and it
is a little hard to isolate and rectify
issues when the community is just split
between two tick rates
but again who knows could be temporary
could be indefinite now if everyone
switched back to matchmaking there would
definitely be positives like undividing
the community which is a good thing the
fact that all quote-unquote serious CS
go players have always been on
third-party matchmaking services like
esea and face it has never been
particularly great for the health of the
scene that said I don't think it's that
great of a look if valve just sort of
callously render face it obsolete let's
not forget that it was services like
esea that literally and this is not an
overstatement literally saved the game
back in 2014 when the cheater issue was
on the brink of killing it before it
ever got started valve owes a fair bit
to face it and I would be surprised if
they just
shut them out overnight because of their
obsession with keeping everything 64
dick speaking of keeping everything 64
dick that is the second much larger
concern for those who didn't see Rob's
put out a really well presented tweet
over the weekend that made the case for
128 tick in a reasoned measured
non-reactionary way that hopefully will
catch the attention of valve and start a
productive dialogue because for those
who don't know and I feel like this is a
common knowledge at this point robs is
actually a Counter-Strike death and has
worked for years bolstering I'm I'm just
kidding guys yeah no he's just a really
influential Pro player whose opinion
carries a ton of weight his hope
obviously is that valve or Geniuses who
will turn subtic into an even better
infrastructure than 128 as is all of our
hopes the question is whether that's
even possible or whether it's worth
taking years and years to do it anyway
that's a conversation for a different
time the point is that right now CS2
finally feels somewhere in the
neighborhood
of decent unless you're holding an angle
don't ever hold an angle kids no that
was the Vanguard
no you can't hold angles like
I literally contemplated taking the op
off of my menu because inevitably you
fall into that trap where you're just
like oh this would be a good round off I
should off here like our money's up
we're good like I this is a good let's
let's let's it's on CT let's off I'm
gonna I'm gonna off I'm gonna off and
you buy an op and then you just get
[__]
zantara's [__] by a [__] allele around
and you're literally just like nope I'm
done